ما أراه فظيعًا لدي
لم أر قط أنه كان أخ
ترى أنه متطرف
عندما تفهم أنه نادر جدًا
لديك هذا الوهم بالحماية
من خلف الشاشة وتشعر به
محمي
[يضحك]
في مرحلة ما أنا عند النافذة هناك
لا شيء يحدث بعد الآن
أرى الناس يشيرون إلى الباب
من باتاكلان من الهواتف المتلألئة
بالتأكيد جرح الناس الذين يحاولون
للاتصال أو توفي مسجلين
أخذ انعكاسي خارج هواتفهم ولكن
هناك المزيد من الطلقات وهناك المزيد من البكاء
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنني لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث
داخل
هناك مقاومة هناك بشكل غير مباشر
هناك رجال سعداء قتلوا
لذلك أغلق هذه النافذة
من الصعب النزول
آخذ شاحن الهاتف
أرتدي حذائي الذي أرتديه
أنا في قميص
ستمضون كل الطريق
نهج ولكن من لا يعتقد أن الأمر كذلك
تذهب إلى هناك لمساعدة الأشخاص الموجودين في
أسوأ حالة هو إما مؤلم
الموت
يبدو واضحا بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى]
هو بحذر
أنت هناك من أجل
أميل قليلاً لأرى الزبدة
بحذر لا حزن عليه هناك
نفس الشيء هناك
لا شيء قليل صمت رهيب
معظم الجثث أمام
باب باتاكلان هناك شخص ما فقط
الذي القميص الأحمر الذي قال م هامبورغ واحد
عشرة أمتار على الرصيف
ذهبت إلى هناك بحذر شديد وبالتالي أنا
انحنى عليه ورأى أنه
كان حيا
وكذلك مع شخص آخر كلهم
تعال إلى الشارع لأنهم
سيكون هناك ويتحقق لأنه هناك
لمرة واحدة يتم كتابتها في منتصف التوأم
في الشارع على أي حال ، لذا قمنا بسحبه
ضعه في الردهة حتى لا يفعلوا
يتعرض لها أو ما شابه ذلك يزيلها
الرجل الأسود يختفي ولذا أطلق النار
ماثيو أكثر على حصان لم
لتتمكن من إغلاق هذا الباب
مثل أسافينه التي أدعوها Benoît
اشرح له ما يحدث
لدي تحت عيني وعشرات الجثث
أخيرًا الأشخاص الذين فروا من خلال المساهمة
بالعشرات أو المئات ولكن هناك
هوامش
لديه وحشية كبيرة وجدت في النسيان
الهاتف يقع على الأرض في
ردهة
لا أعرف لماذا أفقد
الأحذية وأنا أفهم ذلك هناك و
أخذت رصاصة في الاتجاه الذي
شخ
أنا على علم ولكن ما زلت أحب
أننا أخذنا لكمة
شيء سوى هذه الضربة وهو
يستثني مدخني يفيتون
إذا سهرت فمن أنا
على قيد الحياة
[موسيقى]
لم يخبرني ذلك بعد ذلك
انتظرت ستفعل سبع دقائق في ذلك
ألتقط الهاتف لأخبره
أنني كنت على قيد الحياة